Друзі, всім привіт! Сьогодні я приїхав до міської ради міста Трір.
У цій серії я розкажу про іноземців у Німеччині
і їхнє право обиратися до органів місцевої влади.
Цікаво, що в цій історії не обійшлося без українців.
Артур Карась – уродженець Шепетівки, що на Хмельниччині,
проводить будівлею міської ради Тріра і показує кімнату,
де засідає міський Комітет з міграції та інтеграції.
Цей орган представляє інтереси іноземців на муніципальному рівні
та консультує органи місцевої влади з усіх питань, що стосуються іноземних мешканців громади.
До складу комітету зазвичай входять 13 осіб.
І саме цей комітет прагне очолити 27-річний українець.
На вибори 27 жовтня Артур іде на чолі списку "Союзу демократичного Центру",
німецькою - Union der demokratischen Mitte (UdM).
Українець сам зібрав свою команду кандидатів,
а згодом ще й заручився політичною і фінансовою підтримкою
правлячої у ФРН партії Християнсько-демократичний союз.
Комітет з міграції та інтеграції міста Трір існує вже 25 років
Останніми роками комітету вдалося втілити кілька проектів,
однак є ще багато нерозкритого потенціалу.
Ми висунули сильний список на чолі з Артуром Карасем.
Всі люди у списку найрізноманітніших національностей,
і вони можуть багато корисного зробити для нашого міста.
Зі списком пана Карася конкурують ще два.
Діючий Комітет, який підтримує Соціал-демократична партія Німеччини,
і список кандидатів від лівих і зелених, які об'єднали свої сили.
Основна робота Артура – екзаменатор мовного центру.
Він приймає іспити з німецької мови від базового рівня A1 до академічного С2.
Саме робота з іноземцями мотивувала його до активної участі в німецькій політиці.
У зв'язку з тим, що я вже три роки працюю тут, у бюргерсервісі, займаюся роботою з іноземцями,
з людьми, які приїхали до Тріра, як і я сам сім років тому, мене захопила ця тематика.
Я хочу допомогти всім іноземцям, які приїхали сюди.
У нічному Трірі світяться вивіски ресторанів найрізноманітніших кухонь світу.
Зі  110 тисяч населення Тріра 17 % - іноземці.
Причому ще 7 років тому іноземців тут було майже удвічі менше.
Одна з головних причин - криза біженців, зокрема з Сирії.
Їх у Трірі майже три тисячі.
Над вуличною метушнею велично здіймається Порта-Нігра -
Чорна Брама, побудована у часи Римської імперії майже дві тисячі років тому.
А з-за рогу на цей сплеск мультикультуралізму у капіталістичному світі
споглядає подарований китайцями  п'ятиметровий уродженець Тріра - філософ Карл Маркс.
Основна проблема іноземців у Трірі полягає в тому,
що у них не існує одного, скажімо так, комунікаційного центру.
Немає мережі, яка допоможе їм владнати ті чи інші проблеми,
які постають, коли людина приїжджає з нової країни до Німеччини.
Я хотів би щоб це все було дігітально.
Своє головне завдання під час роботи в комітеті Артур вбачає в ініціюванні
спільно з Інтеграційними комітетами міст інших федеральних земель змін до Конституції ФРН,
які б дозволили іноземцям, які тривалий час живуть у Німеччині,
голосувати на виборах міськради і мера.
Ну що ж, давайте познайомимось із іншими кандидатами зі списку
"Союзу демократичного Центру".
Ми приїхали на роботу до нашого наступного героя, який працює на складі.
Олег Таран - уродженець Києва і громадянин Ізраїлю.
Артур цінує досвід Олега, який п'ять років працював у попередньому складі Інтеграційного комітету.
Олег каже, що комітет може робити більше, ніж збиратися раз на кілька місяців
і головним досягненням вважати мовні курси для жінок іммігранток.
Олег із захопленням показує своє основне місце роботи -
повністю роботизований склад, за допомогою якого здійснюється логістика інтернет-торгівлі.
Тільки що ви бачили був збій у роботі,
і тепер мені треба поставити робота на правильне місце, аби він працював далі.
На цьому підприємстві я працюю вже 8 років.
Зараз я виконую обов'язки начальника зміни.
Після роботи Олег бере активну участь у житті єврейської громади Тріра.
Це наша синагога в Трірі. Їй 62 роки. Ходімо всередину!
Це зал нашої громади. Тут ми відзначаємо свята.
А це молитовний зал. Це центр нашого релігійного життя.
Архітектура синагоги вражає своєю простотою і величчю водночас.
Відстоювання інтересів єврейської громади нині особливо актуальне
на тлі зростаючого антисемітизму в Європі.
Олег за нової каденції в Інтеграційному комітеті  прагне, аби міськрада Тріра
запровадила пільговий проїзний квиток для пенсіонерів - пізніх переселенців,
які не можуть мати німецької пенсії.
Комунальна політика є дуже важливим аспектом нашого життя,
іноді вона навіть важливіша за глобальну.
Я вже був у Раді і знову хотів би координувати питання родини і транспорту.
Друзі, а це палац курфюрста Тріра.
Саме тут мені призначила зустріч номер чотири списку УДМ - письменниця Раша Хабаль.
Сирійська письменниця  разом із чоловіком і сином, рятуючись від війни у Сирії,
у 2015 році опинилася у ФРН.
Відтоді Раша живе у Трірі і активно займається творчістю.
Вона отримала стипендію від німецького фонду для роботи над своїм романом.
Сьогодні є одна проблема.
Жінки-іноземки у ФРН мають багато вільного часу,
однак проводять його лише вдома.
І моє завдання - витягнути їх з дому.
Разом з Артуром Раша розробляє пропозиції для своїх виборців.
Одна з них - створення просвітницького клубу для жінок-іноземок.
Їду на наступну  зустріч з кандидатами зі списку в центр Тріра - квартал ресторанів.
Привіт! Ласкаво просимо до ресторану Шемпс. Мене звати Гюлу Темісой.
Це наш внутрішній зал. Це наш кухар Мемет, він саме готує.
А тут працює Салі, він мені - як син. Він зараз випікає піде – це наша національна страва.
За словами Гюлу, їхній з партнером ресторан східної кухні має постійних клієнтів вже багато років.
Влітку у пік сезону власники гарантують 15 робочих місць.
Всі податки платяться, всіх працівників беруть на роботу легально.
Однак після кризи біженців Гюлу, яка вже понад 20 років тому приїхала з Туреччини до ФРН,
помітила збільшення агресивних коментарів на свою адресу.
Я думаю, ми всі живемо в одній громаді,  ми всі належимо до цього суспільства
чи то новоприбулі, чи ті, хто живуть у Німеччині багато років.
Тут, на нашому підприємстві ми мультикультурні.
У нас є працівники з Вірменії, Нігерії, Сирії, Афганістану, Курдистану, Туреччини.
І разом ми зможемо досягти більшого, і тому ми обидва балотуємося до Інтеграційного комітету.
Я живу у Трірі 23 роки, але нас все одно називають іноземцями.
Це слово мені не подобається, ми - люди.
Гюлу в Інтеграційному комітеті хотіла би опікуватися проєктами, які б допомагали людям різних культур
швидше відкривати свою власну справу,
розбиратися у німецьких законах і податковій системі.
Вирушаємо на околиці Тріра до нашого наступного героя.
До 1993 року у цих ангарах стояли американські винищувачі,
тепер тут станція технічного обслуговування автомобілів,
і там на нас чекає номер 5 у списку УДМ – перс Матіас Хашимьян.
Станція техобслуговування спеціалізується на БМВ.
Матіас демонструє унікальні двері на електроприводі моделі Z1.
Машині вже 30 років і вона в чудовому стані
завдяки досконалому знанню Матіасом рідкісних старих моделей  БМВ.
Чоловік приїхав до ФРН з Ірану. Він прийняв християнство і змінив своє ім'я.
Про своє минуле не розповідає.
Ми продаємо деталі. Всі машини, які стоять на подвір'ї, ідуть на запчастини.
Водночас ми також ремонтуємо тут автівки.
Наприклад, цей п'ятий БМВ має проблеми з двигуном - ми їх усунемо,
а ось цей Фольксваген Т4 - зі зламаним зчепленням.
Артур познайомися з Матіасом, коли іранець складав іспит на рівень знання мови В2.
За словами українця, Матіас дуже швидко опанував німецьку до впевненого розмовного рівня
і має неабиякий комунікативний талант.
Артур зрозумів, що люд ина із такими здібностями потрібна у новому складі Інтеграційного комітету.
Я вже 5 років живу у Німеччині. І я вже маю багато німецьких друзів.
Я спостерігаю за іншими іноземцями - вони збираються у групи.
І внаслідок цього мають таке паралельне життя тут в Німеччині.
І я для того балотуюся до комітету,
щоб з моїм досвідом допомогти іншим людям вийти з цього паралельного суспільства.
Артур прийшов до осередку ХДС забирати щойно надруковану агітацію,
яка закликає приходити на вибори до Інтеграційного комітету.
Адже багато іноземців навіть не знають про існування цього органу,
можливість обрати його склад чи навіть балотуватися самому.
А це наразі чи не єдина можливість для іноземців без німецького громадянства
впливати на місцеву політику.
Щоправда, йдеться про неоплачувану добровільну роботу з соціальною користю,
яку у Німеччині називають ерентамт, тобто почесна посада.
Зазвичай засідання комітету проходять вже після 18:00,
тож Артур впевнений, що йому вдасться поєднати  основну роботу із вирішенням проблем іноземців.
У планах в українця й зміцнення української громади.
Йдеться передусім про відкриття української церкви в Трірі і створення українського клубу.
Друзі, вибори відбудуться 27 жовтня,
і у коментарі до цього відео я повідомлю, чи переміг герой нашої серії.
А ви пишіть, що ще би хотіли дізнатися про Німеччину. Побачимось!